hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to sight line the chair now
I played the original sight line a while
back for the first developer kit for the
oculus rift but now they have a sequel
or at least a bigger version of it and
I'm ready to get my mind blown you can
find the original video in the
description below or at an annotation at
the end of this video but let's get to
it now if you don't know about sight
line the game changes as you play it
which makes it very disorienting to get
through anything without losing your
mind and having it explode all over the
walls but let's get to it that's why I'm
here so you don't have to go through the
danger of it hello oh hi hello okay then
we'll come to sight line the chair thank
you was our dog Marvel and chic a cave
of Zeus and this experience all not to
show you the possibilities of the
Solidarity the create variety Awards
that feel real but also the potential of
VR to create the realities that you take
I like anything that you might know
pretty simple look at the plants they
overlap yeah I got it now to the
computer on the right uh-huh
no but for the plan it's changing
changing I will leave it to you to
figure out but remember one thing okay
keep looking around keep observing go
environment because in the world of
sight line you can make things happen
simply by looking okay enjoy the
experience bye I'll try I have no hand
that is weird
also I don't like being sat in the
middle of a dark room alone
it's rather creepy Lukey well in hello
mister changing plan how are you doing
hola mr. changing apple orange and keys
or banana okay is it that time again
this reminds me I don't let go hello
glasses what am I
yeah something gonna happen nothing's
gonna get me oh hi
whoa okay ah you're getting big is it
that time again
okay hi whoa
oh my god whoa
the colors geez well hello mr. stack can
you guys still hear me if I'm facing up
okay they fell you know now it's gonna
happen what the hell oh that's so cool
god I feel like okay I feel like I could
touch them it's so weird that I don't
have a hand in front of my face but that
is ridiculously cool and now you are a
cube uh-huh
you you're gonna make ups and fears but
in the opposite of what you were it's
really cool
oh my gotten sound too it's all around
me wicked cool
oh man wicked cool bro to use old lingo
what is that that is not a cube over
there huh whoa okay well I have a body
and I know that
my guy or girl glad let's just BAPS okay
butterflies now well then I didn't know
those butterfly o´clock what what in the
world oh oh that's new uh-uh
please Oh Birds okay a panics for no
reason not don't let go this is
beautiful this is beautiful oh my god
it's beautiful it's so peaceful and
pretty I think I'm gonna vomit
okay okay Tower gone didn't need it
anyway we can live without towers as
long as I got my chair I'm good
are you okay that's new would you come
from for any of you okay then
well hello I'm creating a forest with my
mind I wonder what else I can create I
literally just gotta be sitting here do
i I didn't I didn't even need a
controller did I okay what am I supposed
to look at next uh all right then
okay I like it so far but whoa
butterflies are getting close to my face
well it's getting darker getting darker
it's getting a lot darker don't like it
don't like the dark just bow hello
oh my goodness okay what the hell what
the hell what the hell what is this
Dishonored okay well then okay well then
I guess that's just how it's gonna be
Oh water on my face hello rain you're
beautiful looks like everything else in
this game oh man there's trippy as hell
is this England is that one of them
English British telephone boxes where's
the TARDIS
wait that's was that that what that did
I hear some good why wait a minute
hey you're changing what Jenny very
subtly but I notice it oh come on
cut okay hi I did someone lose a car
okay how am i doing am I good am I still
good am I still good here hi
okay it's God why not what else is new
and something changed I don't know what
though these buildings are just row hi
hi hi mr. Lampe okey-dokey then
I'm in a room who I am
how's it go delicious I want some yeah
that piggy don't look so good
then again double-checking everything
there I don't really want any of that
I'm okay thanks
why is it that every time I shout okay
balls in my face did not request balls
in my balls in my dinner who tea-bagged
my dear kick booty bagged my hole okay
some of them are now boxes ah
is there a tiny box Tim buried in that
big brick boxes I ready then what's with
the lamp
oh my dinners gone Lisa what the uh-oh
walls are closing in
still got my lamp I love this lamp but I
don't like this Oh God
do not I do not okay no don't thank you
I'm going out of my own head I can
actually see my own head there why do I
have a body it doesn't count
oh really
oh my lamp no laughs oh hello uh hi that
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy don't
panic I wasn't scoffs screaming
incoherently coherently kaboom a I blow
it up with my brain so cool I am oh my
god that's so trippy I'm flying I'm
flying through space wow that is cool
does anyone else reminded of the game
homeworld can I blow these I'm blowing
them up with my brain
Kabam
yeah you too you looked at me funny now
you die yo you thought you just don't
run from me do you way over there boom
your big one what the oh hey Wow
blow one of them up I got a look at this
one boom yeah okay they want a
conglomerate I will not let you okay
boom what about you big guy you want to
blow up there you go
you you're a mind no not you god damn
what am I supposed to go hello bye Bucky
who you whine space white space wine is
there really space wine over there whoa
that is so messed up oh my god is so
cool
oh-ho-ho yeah my space wine is turned
into a space moon with that space moon
looks like what okay that's a space cake
now don't know what happened to my space
wine uh no space wine back good you're
gonna block don't know you
yo-yo your BAM i'ma blow up the Sun uh
nope okay Sun gone I love the Sun
congratulations everybody everyone's on
earth who's gonna die oh that don't look
good
what the um okay whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
am I in the Internet am i on reboot
reboot
I screwed some up I blow the Sun and
everything went to [ __ ] what the hell oh
hi hi friend you're looking spiky and
deadly as ever
please go [ __ ] off okay one eye hi hi I
take some of these and go three think
your life for a second okay
they're getting closer ain't you yeah he
will you're getting much looser okay
this looks bad this is exactly the
situation I didn't want to end up in I
was never gonna die it would not be by
this okay all right bye okay whoa oh my
goodness oh don't make me fall please
don't make me fall don't know shut up
don't make me fall
you make me salt oh I swear if you make
me fall do not don't oh god oh god oh
god oh god
oh fall I you son of a [ __ ] I hate you
uh-uh-uh-uh
okay oh God
oh oh oh oh okay okay then okay then was
that it that it was that it
my done did I win did i won did i won i
think i won
oh my god that was awesome
oh that was awesome Wow
let's go home I could turn off the body
that would have been a little less
disorienting but oh that was so cool
oh my god that was like the coolest ever
oh I love that
Oh beautiful beautifully done Oh God
every moment of that you're slightly
disorienting but God that was Oh pure
simple fun so anyway hope you guys enjoy
that check out the other oculus rift
videos I've got then split up into
horror and regular awesome stuff you can
check him out in the description below
they're all great
everything I've played so far has been
fantastic on the angka strip this one
really is a testament of what you can do
with this sort of thing so either way
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye
Oh God whoa what is that what is that
Thanks houses in a game my brain is
gonna explode